Jillian Michaels the woman's name is
synonymous with early 2000s diet culture
which was arguably probably the worst
era of diet culture thus far she called
people selfish it's not all about you
don't be so selfish pathetic you're not
acting so strong you're acting pathetic
encourage people to work out so hard
that they threw up let me see it
throw up right now we're gonna have
problems and it kind of seemed like she
legit enjoyed it and while The Biggest
Loser may be behind us thank God she now
is spreading tough love through YouTube
Instagram and her podcast keeping it
real the woman certainly doesn't
sugarcoat anything and today we're going
to see her own tough love approach to
feeding herself in a day hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at everything Jillian Michaels eats in a
day a reminder please to read my
disclaimer and also check out my trigger
warning as we will be discussing very
restrictive behaviors so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
guys are new here help your girl out hit
that subscribe button and don't forget
to follow me on Instagram and tick tock
on Abby's kitchen before we get too far
into things let me tell you about my
sponsor green Chef so I've been spending
the past few weeks in the states sort of
on holiday but also sort of even more
stressed because I'm trying to work and
I'm trying to be a super Hands-On mom at
the same time so dinner most nights
isn't exactly my top priority so I'm
always really excited when my green Chef
box comes because it low-key saves me on
hectic nights green Chef is a ccof
certified organic meal kit subscription
service that offers specific options for
a wide range of Lifestyle files like
vegan vegetarian fast and fit
Mediterranean keto or paleo and
gluten-free all of their kits contain
step-by-step recipes along with farm
fresh produce and other organic
sustainably sourced ingredients the
recipes are super easy especially the
fast and fit meals which are ready in 25
minutes or less and everything is
pre-portioned out so you really don't
have to think about it like it saves me
a lot of thinking when I'm already not
really in my usual routine at home this
week I made these spicy chicken and
broccoli stir fry I love stir fries in
general but I'm always looking for new
sauces other than just like a basic
Teriyaki and this spicy ginger lime
aioli that it came with really took it
to the next level I also got a kit for
beef adobo bell pepper stew and Italian
shrimp Garden Bowl so obviously lots of
different protein options and cultural
flavors to kind of keep things
interesting plus green Chef makes it
super easy to customize orders if you've
got some people in the house who are
vegan and others who are gluten free
Etc so if you want to try a green Chef
for yourself use my code abbey60 to get
free shipping and check out
greenchef.com in the description below
for more details all right Jillian get
at me so I'm gonna try to fly in
graphics so I can give you guys visuals
since I can't you know I can't make
everything I mean most people do have to
make or buy the food that they eat in a
day so I'm not sure why that's such an
outrageous suggestion but go on Jillian
let's hear it I'm big into longevity not
looking to lose weight so all of the
current research by all the top experts
suggest that eating less food is less
oxidative stress allows you to live
longer and eating less often more
importantly which is why you guys are
hearing all the time about intermittent
fasting I would love to see this
research from these top experts that
she's referencing I'm just hoping this
expert knows this stuff because as usual
it feels like Jillian is not seeing the
forest from the trees so Jillian's
argument is grounded in this concept of
autophagy or the degradation of cellular
components I spoke to my colleague Eric
Williamson who is an expert in this
space who did an amazing webinar on this
so you should definitely check it out
but in short the research has found that
doing a 21 hour fast every day increases
a lifespan by 17 that's that's pretty
significant but and this is a big but
almost all of our research on autophagy
and fasting has been done on rats and
we're different than rats in a few key
ways their metabolism is more Dynamic
and over six times faster their heart
rate is almost five times faster we live
27 times longer their protein turnover
is almost 10 times faster and they
voluntarily Run 10 to 20 kilometers a
day and most of us do not have do you
have any snacks
and while autophagy is important to
clean up damaged cell matter too much
autophagy is potentially also dangerous
in fact some mice breeds in that
research actually live less long when
fasting as for the argument that eating
less food period also helps you live
longer there is some basis for this
argument namely that it keeps our body
fat levels low and also possibly helps
to suppress mtor activity which is
mainly associated with reducing cancer
and heart disease but as Eric puts it to
me calorie restriction May theoretically
increase the length of life but it
usually comes at the expense of quality
of life extreme hunger obsessive
thoughts about food suppressed metabolic
rate Etc so Eric suggests focusing Less
on fasting or calorie restriction for
autophagy and rather focusing on
exercise which not only stimulates
autophagy but also targets mtor
activities in the muscle where it's
needed in conclusion is a life of
starving really a life at all just some
food for thought Jillian first thing I
do is I cheat that 12-hour window to 14
hours with what's called a dirty fast
leave it to Jillian Michaels to fit so
much unnecessary moralizing language in
one short sentence but FYI a dirty fast
is kind of a made-up pseudofast that
allows a small amount of calories
usually under 100 calories during the
fast now we don't have any research
specifically on dirty fasts we can
assume that you may end up with the
calorie restriction benefits of a fast
but lose out on the autophagy Digestive
and in most cases insulin suppressing
benefits of a traditional clean fast
ugh I hate that these words are coming
out of my mouth right now so I have
organic coffee really important that
coffee is organic because it is a very
heavily sprayed crop with pesticides
herbicides fungicides so organic coffee
and I just put heavy whipping cream in
it that's organic okay but is it really
imperative that you drink organic coffee
let's talk about it so first of all just
because a coffee isn't labeled certified
organic doesn't mean they aren't using
organic processes it's actually really
expensive to get an Organic
certification and it can take years of
production for eligible so there are a
lot of products out there that may be
using organic growing practices but just
can't afford the fancy title second
organic crops aren't necessarily
pesticide free they are just using
non-synthetic pesticides and natural is
not necessarily safer or ecologically
better but regardless of the pesticide
Source what's important here is that we
don't pick up a coffee bean and like eat
it raw like an apple the bean is the
seed of the fruit the Flesh of the fruit
is discarded and the seed is put through
an extensive drying and roasting process
research suggests that this roasting
process removes 99.8 percent of the
pesticides present so you know my drill
on coffee let the people just have the
way they like it without a lecture next
why why am I doing that it's organic
heavy whipping cream okay so it has no
carbs and no protein because it's
protein and carbs in particular that
break the overnight fast okay so I
really don't think any of this is worth
harping on but FYI whipping cream is not
pure fat it does have small amounts of
protein and carbs again we don't have
any good data on dirty fasting but it's
very possible that this would halt the
autophagy process the migratory Motor
complex for good digestion and possibly
even stimulate insulin as well on my
most awesome days I will have two
organic eggs and a piece of whole grain
toast I'll have organic grass-fed Greek
yogurt with all different berries and
fruits and cocoa nibs and nuts I'm sorry
what does it even mean most awesome days
is this like when she's good and eats
clean I guess we'll never know but this
meal does sound amazing we've got
protein and healthy fats in the eggs
yogurt and nuts and fiber rich carbs in
the toast and berries like it sounds
like a perfect sweet and savory combo
meal and we love to see it and then when
I just I'm kind of like I don't feel
like it I'll have two pieces of organic
whole grain bread with peanut butter no
peanuts are not the devil that is a lie
about anti-nutrients and food that's
baloney but at least we can agree on
something and she is right despite what
those carnivores will try to convince
you of anti-nutrients are not the devil
the major anti-nutrient found in peanuts
is phytic acid which does slightly
reduce the absorption of iron and zinc
but this is really not a major concern
in healthy individuals eating a normaled
varied diet it's also worth pointing out
that peanut butter and peanuts actually
have the highest amount of protein
compared are two other nuts in the nut
Kingdom so I say that this is a great
simple meal for those days when you're
feeling a little met or when I'm really
kind of like Aaron I'm going to be less
than responsible I will have an organic
everything bagel with organic cream
cheese and wild caught locks it's that
bad this poor woman like why does she
need to repent for her irresponsible
Bagel choice and try to convince us that
it's not that bad I'm like no one would
have ever thought that a bagel with lox
is bad until you convinced everyone
watching that it was like
me not a monster lunch eater in fact
it's really more of a snack and the
reason is because I'll have a bigger
snack and a smaller kind of lunch so
that I end up eating less at dinner okay
so what I'm getting out of this is that
she has a late breakfast then she fits
in two snacks we will call them a small
lunch and a big snack and then a small
dinner and I mean if that works for her
there are some metabolism benefits to
front loading calories and our carbs
earlier on in the day and of course some
folks will find that they sleep much
better without a heavy meal before bed
at the end of the day what really
matters here is that you've met your
nutrient needs somehow some way in the
day or even as an average over a few
days to be honest I'll have like a piece
of fruit and a little bit of protein
like some rotisserie chicken uh some
thing of tuna salad organic string
cheese and a piece of fruit not nothing
crazy some protein and some carbs and
some
okay so we will call this meal two it's
basically a small snack that's balanced
we're looking at like maybe 200 calories
tops so yeah she was definitely right
about the light lunch situation so I
tried to make this kind of a
monster-sized salad and it could be like
a healthy cob I leave off the bacon I
put the dressing on the side
Mediterranean with grilled salmon on top
taco salad right without the fried
little taco things always dressing on
the side basically big salad protein
complex carbs dressing on the side I'm
sorry the early 2000s have called and
you've always got to have the dressing
on the side never a crispy thing in
sight ever I mean God forbid they tossed
the salad or a crouton got mixed in we
would obviously have to send it back if
the salad is on top I send it back
I'm just being sassy I think this sounds
delicious minus the old school diet tips
I mean I guess Jillian made her Mark in
diet culture during the early 2000s
she's kind of got to stay true to her
brand with these tips and I'm not an
idiot I know that these things can help
to slash calories but why are we so
concerned about cutting calories when
earlier on in this video we talked about
not trying to lose weight you're
confused I'm confused she's confused
we're all a bit confused now by the time
I had dinner I'm feeling pretty full
because I eat all of that fiber and I'm
gonna eat less and this is where I
generally will go out to eat so if we go
for sushi
um I don't have rolls but I do have
sushi salmon sushi all have Yellow Tail
Sashimi I'll have edamame I'll have the
seaweed salad always get the seaweed
salad so good for you try to get wild
caught salmon which is not so easy to
find when you go for sushi okay so
basically she's using a classic low
calorie preload tactic to reduce the
Temptation or appetite to eat the foods
that are maybe higher in carbs or
calories in General while eating out and
it is an evidence-based suggestion with
research finding that a small salad
reduced subsequent calorie intake by
seven percent and a large salad by 12
percent soup would top the charts at a
20 reduction if you go for Mexican I do
the fajitas light oil I don't generally
do the tortillas so basically just kind
of like some semi-stein vegetables and
meat with some spices I have to assume
chefs in La just get used to these
requests but personally for me
I would just like make this at home if
we go for Italian I tend to get like the
bronzino or like the grilled protein
with tons of veggies again no carbs in
sight just vegetables and fish and
Branzino is delicious but I would feel
personally victimized if I went to an
Italian restaurant and didn't have a
bite of pizza or pasta just me
I know it's not just me try to make this
stuff at home because I will have like
five different veggies so I feel really
full and I'm getting tons of fiber so
there seems to be a real Obsession here
with like stuffing herself full of water
and fiber and avoiding any added fats to
make her feel full on a small amount of
calories which is again very strange for
someone who claims not to be interested
in losing weight should you get the
spring rolls that aren't fried and like
rice paper and some sort of Veggie dish
sure does oil and some salt in it but I
try to say light oil yeah so this is
starting to feel a little bit like
Victoria Beckham's diet with a bit more
variety mixed in but the bones are
basically the same Chinese is tough to
eat out but my wife music is sick kung
pao chicken at home which is white meat
chicken steamed rice all the peppers and
she does really light oil and keeps it
clean I don't think Chinese food needs
to be hard to eat out if you have a
balanced healthy relationship with food
but I will say her wife's version sounds
amazing and I would totally stay and if
someone want to make that for me minus
the moralizing clean eating language
don't do dessert I don't drink often
there are some health benefits to
alcohol in moderation so Jillian's
talking about the health benefits of
wine or alcohol in moderation and she's
right alcohol-like wine is rich in the
antioxidants like Resveratrol which is
being linked to reduce inflammation when
consumed in moderation but the key here
is moderation unlike with other toxins
like smoking which has a pretty linear
relationship with use and mortality risk
alcohol has a j shaped curve so a little
may be helpful but much more can be very
very bad personally I don't believe in
adding alcohol for its health benefits
but if you do enjoy drinking like I do a
couple drinks a week likely won't hurt
my supplement regimen is insane and I'm
not gonna lie to you guys this is nuts
this is where it might be a little less
relatable I'm sorry was that whole
interview that we just watched supposed
to be relatable
I take
um a lot of multi-collagen I add matcha
green tea powder Cylon cinnamon turmeric
and ginger I put a monster two monstrous
groups of that in my coffee was this the
same coffee she used to stretch her
dirty fast because if so yes collagen
alone will break a traditional fast
since protein can elicit an insulin
response which halts the autophagy blood
sugar and a digestive benefits of
fasting then I take krill oil you guys
know I like that better than fish oil
because you don't have to worry about it
spoiling as much and you don't have the
heavy metals okay so she may be on
selling with the krill oil love krill
oil like fish oil is rich in heart
healthy Omega-3s but because Krill
typically feeds on algae and fish oil is
typically produced by larger Predator
fish fish oils have higher risk of heavy
metal contamination now while krill oil
does have lower doses of EPA and DHA
than traditional fish oil it appears
that it may be more by available which
kind of equals the playing field its
antioxidant content also has been shown
to neutralize free radicals 48 greater
than fish oil that said I think both are
great options so choose whatever you can
afford and access and make sure to look
for a third party tested product before
you buy um again I like the Align
Naturals greens powder like it even has
a pre and probiotic even though I take
that as well it's all organic all
organic to that
greens I also add a product
um called Miracle Reds I add it because
is I want all the Reds and the blues and
the purples all organic of course can't
not be organic I'm pretty sure she's got
like a partnership with this Olea brand
which is surprisingly undisclosed and if
that is the case that's a whole other
problem but you guys know what I say
about those greens powders or in this
case Reds powders they're powdered
multivitamins they're not a replacement
for real food heart stop and since she's
clearly getting in a ton of antioxidant
Rich fruits and veggies in our day this
all seems remarkably obsolete my
symbiotic so a symbiotic is a pre and
probiotic I'm a big supporter of pre and
probiotics but it's important that if
you have any specific gut related
concerns to speak to a dietitian about
which probiotic strains and prebiotics
will be best and not triggering for you
well another day another over-the-top
diet recall from our girl Jillian
Michaels I feel like not much has
changed with Jillian since we last
reviewed her diet let's be honest and
the best I am other than the fact that
her team asked me to come onto her
podcast and I was like oh I feel like
I'm just kind of gonna be talking to
myself not sure it's my vibe I'm just
kind of assuming that if people who
follow her are really into that no pain
no gain rhetoric there's probably not
much I can do to change that in a single
podcast app but let me know below if you
guys think I should reconsider and on
that note that's all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leaving a
comment below on who or what you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]